علينا واجب ومسؤولية
دعم أهلنا في غزة
وأقل ما يمكننا فعله بالطبع هو النشر
عن ذلك عبر الإنترنت، وهو
أمر يخدع القمع، وهو سؤال المقاومة هي
الجواب، فلسطين طويلة
غزة، وأعتقد أنهم خائفون من ذلك
ببساطة.  تغطية الحقيقة وعندما
ننظر إلى مقتل الشيخ أبو
مثلا نرى ذلك من أعراض
الحرب على الصحافة وهي في الأساس
حرب على الظهور وهي
محاولة أه جعل الناس يعتقدون
أن ما هو  ما يحدث
للفلسطينيين هو
إلى حد ما أه عملية طبيعية وأنه في
الحقيقة لا ينبغي أن يكون هناك أي تدقيق
يستهدف إسرائيل وما تفعله لذلك عندما
ترى المشاهير الذين اختاروا
الانخراط بشكل أعمق في
القضية الفلسطينية فهناك رد
وهناك  هي الإجراءات المتخذة ضدهم،
هناك وحدات موجودة داخل
الجيش الإسرائيلي
خصيصًا لغرض
حرب وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي عندما يكون لديك على سبيل
المثال موقع ويب مثل Twitter أو X كما
هو معروف الآن حيث يمكن لملايين الأشخاص
رؤية المعلومات التي ينشرها الأشخاص  مثلي
أطرح أن هناك
تهديدًا حقيقيًا
للهيمنة الكاملة في حرب المعلومات التي
تشنها إسرائيل وعليهم أن يعرفوا
أننا نرفض أن نكون صامتين وأن ما
يرونه مما أفعله على الإنترنت يمثل 1٪
من  ما أفعله وعليهم أن يدركوا
أننا نعمل بعدة طرق
غير مرئية لهم
بشكل واضح على الإنترنت
ولن نتراجع لذلك على سبيل المثال منذ
يومين فقط أغنية لي
علامة استفهام إرهابية  الذي حصل على
5.5 مليون مشاهدة منذ إصداره في
عام 2011، تم حذفه بواسطة YouTube. ومن
المثير للاهتمام أنه قيل لنا أن ذلك كان بسبب
تضمين محتوى رسومي ولكن
ذلك لم يكن يمثل مشكلة على مدار الـ
14 عامًا الماضية تقريبًا، لذا فهذا
مثال واحد ولكن تشمل الأمثلة الأخرى  إن
الحملة التي قامت بها مجموعة الضغط "نحن نؤمن
بإسرائيل" والتي لديها علاقة وثيقة جدًا
مع السفارة الإسرائيلية
والتي يقودها أيضًا لوك أورست، وهو
شخص كان في السابق أحد أعضاء جماعات الضغط
لشركات الأسلحة في هذا البلد
وأيضًا "نحن نؤمن بإسرائيل" هي
مشروع بوم وهو خشية
جماعة الضغط الإسرائيلية في هذا البلد الآن
أطلقوا حملة في مارس
2022 لإزالة موسيقاي من
Spotify من منصة البث الآن
ولحسن الحظ لم يكن ذلك ناجحًا
لأننا تمكنا من طلب
دعم أه  شخصيات بارزة جدًا في
العالم من أه محمد حديد أم أيضًا
حصلنا على دعم مارك روفالو
حصلنا على دعم نومي تشومسكي حصلنا على
دعم من أخوة كور حصلنا على
دعم من أه موسيقيين بارزين في
هذا البلد روجر ووترز أيضًا أم
وماذا  لقد قاموا بالتوقيع على عريضة
والتحدث علنًا ومطالبة Spotify بعدم
الخضوع لهذه الحملة التي قام بها
اللوبي الإسرائيلي لإزالة موسيقاي
وزُعم أن موسيقاي كانت بمثابة
تحريض على العنف ضد أه
إسرائيل كما تعلم كان هناك  مرحلة في
عام 2022 حيث يمكنني القول أنه تم إلغاء حوالي 80٪ من
عروضي ولكن لحسن الحظ
تمكنا من القيام بجولة في بداية
هذا العام ومن بين حوالي ثمانية
عروض تم إلغاء واحد منها فقط بنجاح
بعد حملة قام بها
اللوبي الإسرائيلي  لذلك ما زلنا نضغط، ومرة
أخرى أرى أن حملة مثل هذه
تعكس شيئين:
الأول يعكس هشاشة الفكرة الصهيونية، وبالتالي فإن
فكرة أنه يمكن أن يكون لديك
ترتيب اجتماعي غير عادل وقسوة على
نطاق صناعي تستهدف ملايين
الفلسطينيين ك  الوضع الراهن، لذا فإن
الحملة ضدي هي امتداد
لحملة إسكات الفلسطينيين كما
نعلم، بين عامي 2015 و2018،
كان هناك أكثر من 500 فلسطيني اعتقلهم
الجيش والشرطة الإسرائيلية بتهمة
جريمة التحريض على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي، وكان من
بينهم أطفال  تم اعتقالي عندما كان عمري
14 عامًا بسبب أشياء
كانوا يقومون بتحميلها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي. أنا لا
أدين الأشخاص الذين يؤلههم
الآخرون، الأشخاص الذين يتطلع إليهم
الآخرون، لا أدينهم، ما أفعله هو الحداد على
حياة هؤلاء الأشخاص.  رائعون مثلهم
الذين لم يتمكنوا أبدًا من تحقيق
إمكاناتهم بسبب الأنظمة السياسية
التي تقمعهم، وفي هذه الحالة
بالنسبة للفلسطينيين، فأنت
لست أفضل أو أكثر أهمية من
شخص ما الآن تحت طائراتهم من طراز
F-16 من طراز F35 أو رؤية  إن دبابة إسرائيلية
قادمة نحوهم هي في الأساس الإنسانية
جسد، وعندما يتأذى جزء من الإنسانية
فإننا جميعا نتألم، وعلينا واجب ومسؤولية
دعم
شعبنا في غزة وأقل ما يمكننا
فعله بالطبع هو النشر عن ذلك عبر الإنترنت.
هل هذا هو أقل ما يمكنك فعله، فهذه
وجهة نظري حول هذا الموضوع على الرغم من أنني
أعتقد أيضًا أن المشاهير ليسوا
هم كل شيء وفي نهاية كل ما
نتحدث عنه، علينا أيضًا التركيز على
مكان مراكز السياسة  القوة والطرق
المادية التي تعمل بها إسرائيل
في مجتمعنا، ما أود قوله
هو لا تخافوا على المستقبل لأن
الواقع هو أن إسرائيل لا تملك
السيطرة على السرد، وبالتالي
فإنك في الواقع تضر نفسك من خلال عدم
الاستجابة للخطاب.  تدفق الدعم
الذي تتمتع به فلسطين في العالم، وفي
الواقع ستجد أن
الغالبية العظمى من البشرية عليك أن
تتذكر أن غالبية دول
العالم مرت بعملية
إنهاء الاستعمار، فهي مستعمرات سابقة
لذلك فإن غالبية دول
العالم  إنها تحتوي على سكان يعتبرون
أنفسهم رعايا ما بعد الاستعمار،
وبالتالي فهم يرتبطون بطريقة عميقة
بالمحنة الفلسطينية، وفي الواقع، هناك عدد
أكبر بكثير من الناس في العالم يقفون إلى
جانب الفلسطينيين أكثر من الذين يقفون إلى
جانب قوات الاحتلال الإسرائيلية، لذا
انضموا إلى بقيتنا  والوقوف مع
بقيتنا ودعم
فلسطين